[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه نستعرض ونصدم معكم ابرز المستجدات
وفي العناوين
[موسيقى]
روسيا تقول انها افشلت هجوما اوكرانيا
بالمسيرات على شبه جزيره القرم تسقط 20
مسيره روسيه
الحكومه السودانيه تتهم وكيمياء والدعم
السريع والاتحاد الاوروبي يصف اغتيال
سلطنه عمان تعلن عن اتفاق وشيك بين ايران
والولايات المتحده لاطلاق صلاح امريكيين
محتجزين في طهران
لتطويق الصين في المحيط الهادئيني الجديد
تسمح للجيش الامريكي باستخدام قواعدها
العسكريه
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا اعلان سلاح الجو
الاوكراني اسقاط صاروخ كروز وعشرين مسيره
اطلقتها روسيا خلال هجوم الليلي جديد
وخارج الى القوات الاوكرانيه تمكنت من
اعتراض صاروخ من اصل اربعه اطلقتها روسيا
من بحر قزوين فيما اصابه ثلاث صواريخ
منشات
وسط البلاد من جهه اخرى مشاهدينا اعلن
حاكم شبه جزيره القرم ان القوات الروسيه
اسقطت 9 مسيرات فوق اراضيها دون تسبب في
خسائر في المقابل افادت السلطات في شبه
جزيره القرم التي تسيطر عليها روسيا بوقوع
هجوم بطائرات مسيره اوكرانيه قالت انها
اسقطت تسعا منها واعلن رئيس جمهوريه القرم
سيرجي اكسينوف عن انفجار مسيره في بلده
التي تقع في وسط شبه جزيره القرم ورغم عدم
وقوع اصابات افاد رئيس شبه الجزيره بان
نوافذ في عدد من المباني السكنيه تحتمت
بالفعل في البلده على بعد 40 كيلومترا من
سيمفيربول
قالت المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه الروسيه
مارزخرف في مقابله مع العربي حين العمليه
العسكريه في اوكرانيا تهدف لوقف اراقه
الدماء في دومباس الذي استمر لثمانيه
اعوام
واشارت زخارفا الى ان عده دول قدمت رؤيتها
في مبادرات لحل الازمه الاوكرانيه
والمبادره الصينيه هي الاكثر تماشيا مع
نهج موسكو
الحرب في دومباس بدات منذ ثمان سنوات
بداتها بتوجيه دباباتها بعد ان قام الغرب
والولايات المتحده بالانقلاب في اوكرانيا
قتل خلالها 15 الف شخص منهم عدد كبير من
المدنيين بدانا العمليه العسكريه الخاصه
من اجل ايقاف اراقه الدم لكن الغرب استغل
هذه الازمه من اجل بدء حرب هجينه ضدنا ما
يقومون به هو ضد اي دوله لها سياسه خارجيه
مستقله لذلك سينتهي الهجوم الاوكراني
المضاد بانتصارنا لاننا على الجانب الصحيح
من التاريخ ولاننا ندافع عن القيم
العائليه والحريه الصادقه الخاليه من الشر
والعنف وندافع عن كل ما يعتبر جزءا من
حضارتنا
معنا مراسل العربيه اهلا بك عبد الجواد
واخر التفاصيل حول الوضع في شبهيه القرن
بعد هذه الهجمات التي تعرضت لها بالمسيره
الاوكرانيه
صباح الخير احمد نعم بالفعل صحيح ما ذكرت
حاكموا شبه جزيره القرمشي اكسونا في يتحدث
عن اسقاط تسع مسيرات اوكرانيه حلقت فوق
شبه الجزيره خلال الليله الماضيه يدور
الحديث عن اسقاط سته منها بضربات وسائل
الدفاع الجوي هذا ما سمعه سكان المناطق
الوسطى في شبه الجزيره وقاموا بنشر مقاطع
فيديو تظهر بعض الانفجارات في سماء
المدينه ايضا طبعا تم التشويش على ثلاثه
مسيرات في المنطقه ذاتها وتم اسقاطها دون
اللجوء لاستخدام وسائل الدفاع الجوي احدى
المسيرات كما تتحدث المصادر الرسميه من
هناك ماده تتحدث عن ان احدى المسيره
المسيره ادت الى حدوث انفجار ما ادى الى
تحطم الزجاج في العديد من المباني اضرار
طبعا ماديه كما يدور الحديث لكن دون وقوع
اي اضرار بشريه ليست هي المره الاولى التي
تتعرض بها شبه جزيره
وغيرها من تلك المناطق تتلقى ضربات عاده
يعني خلال الاشهر الاخيره الماضيه خاصه
عندما اصل سيارات هي العنصر الاساسي
واصبحت تلعب دور محوري في عمليه الصراع
بين موسكو
لكن يعني تسع مسيرات في ليله واحده الكثير
من سكان تلك المناطق تتحدثون عن ان هذا
رقم قد يكون قياسي اذا ما تم مقارنته
بايام اخرى اذا ما يدور الحديث عن منطقه
في وسط شبه الجزيره لذلك طبعا كما تتحدث
المصادر الرسميه تم نشر العديد من وسائل
الدفاع الجوي وهذا ما ادى الى تعطيل
واسقاط هذا العدد من المسيرات
ايضا في موضوع عندي صله مسلوب التوتر
مازال اخذ اخذا في التصاعد بين فاغنر وبين
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ما اخر فصول هذه
الخلافات بين الطرفين
احمد يعني في اخر التصريحات مؤسس مجموعه
وبان مجموعته لن تذهب للتوقيع مع وزاره
الدفاع البعض راح اتحدث قد تكون محاوله من
الدفاع لدمج هؤلاء المقاتلين بين العناصر
المقاتله في الجنوب الاوكراني لكن فاجنر
ومؤسسها
كشخص يمتلك شركه عسكريه خاصه تقوم بتنفاذ
مهمات مقابل مبالغ ماديه لن يكون معني
بهذا الموضوع
طيب نحن
سنكتفي بهذا القدر معك عبد الجواد ونعود
لك ربما في سياق نشرات مقبله اعتذر منك
وشكرا لك عبد الجواد الرش مشاهدينا نلتقي
مباشره الى هذا الاجتماع لوزاره الدفاع
وهذه الكلمه ايضا لوزير الدفاع الامريكي
اوكرانيا دائم ونحن نبقى متحدين
واعزميين على اكمال مهمهنا ونستمر في
التوجه الاستراتيجي
للتاكد من ان اوكرانيا لديها القدرات
لحمايه مواطنيها واراضيها وايضا
للسيطره
والانتصار على حمله بوتين وهذا يبين
الاهداف وقد
ركزنا على مساعده اوكرانيا في حمايه
مواطنيها والبنى التحتيه بالاصول الموجوده
لديها من دفاعات جويه
وتحسين المواطنين من اصل لهجه مع
التصاروخيه هذه
المجموعه
ودعمها من انظمه الدفاع تعزز قدره
اوكرانيا ونواصل
البحث في تقديم الدفاعات الجويه والذخيره
التي تحتاجها اوكرانيا لدفاع عن مواطنيها
كما نواصل تبني هذه المساعدات
للتاقلم مع التغيرات على الارض واحتياجات
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه في الاجتماع
الماضيه اعلنا عن مبادره بقيادات التنمارك
وهولندا
لتقديم
دفاعات جويه بماهيها بما فيها 16
وكما نتطلع لسماع مزيد عن تقدمكم اليوم
ولاحقا سنسمع من بولندا والمانيا حول مهمه
المحافظه على
الدخل ما لدى اوكرانيا من الدبابات
والتحالفاتنا هي لتقديم التدريب والثاني
هو لتقديم الدبابات
واود ان نشيد باعضاء هذه المجموعه الذين
بداوا في تغطيه الاحتياجات الطويله الامد
لقوه اوكرانيا وعلينا نضمن ان لديهم
الدفاعات التي يحتاجونها
للدفاع عن بلادهم من
الاعتداءات المستقبليه من روسيا
اليوم سنسمع من
الجنرال وعدد من زملائنا حول خطط التدريب
وعملنا حول المساعده في ساحه المعركه
وبالتالي نعد اوكرانيا للوضع الراهن
وتحدد مستقبل القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
سيداتي وسادتي
الطموحات الامبرياليه
ادت لمعاناه الشعب الاوكراني بشكل ليس له
نظير ونحن نشيد
بالشجاعه والالتزام
الاوكراني للدفاع عن وطنهم وامنه نبقى
متحدين وسنجتمع دائما لمواجهه التحديات
والظروف المتغيره ومعا سنقف مع اوكرانيا
لطالما احتاج الامر والان سنسمح لزملائ نا
في الاعلام ان يغادروا
مشاهدينا كلنا معكم في متابعه لهذا الجانب
من اجتماع وزراء دفاع حلف الناتو في
بروكسيل وهذه الكلمه لوزير الدفاع
الامريكي الذي قال فيها ان طموحات روسيه
التي وصفها بالامبرياليه تتسبب في معاناه
الشعب الاوكراني بشكل لا مثير له وقال
ايضا
بالاسلحه والذخيره وكل الامكانات الضروريه
واضاف ايضا وزير الدفاع الامريكي مشاهدينا
ان افاد انه افاد بانه واشنطن مستمر في
دعم اوكرانيا بالاسلحه حتى الانتصار
نشرت الشرطه الاوكرانيه لقطات مثيره تظهر
عمليه انتشار امراه حيه من تحت الانقاض
وقالت الشرطه انها انجبت امراه ورجلا من
تحت ركام مباني دمرتها الضربه الروسيه
خلال عمليه انقاذ استمرت لعده ساعات
[موسيقى]
والمزيد مشاهدينا من تفاصيل الحرب
الاوكرانيه الروسيه مع الزميل شراء
الصلواتي اهلا احمد وكما تابعنا وضمن
استراتيجيه تتماشى مع الجغرافيا المواقع
تحاول موسكو هذه المره تدارك الخسائر التي
تكبدتها قوتها في اوكرانيا بموافقتها على
تجنيد الجيش للمجرمين لتعزيز خطوطها
الدفاعيه في ميدان الحرب التي تدخل عامها
الثاني مجلس النواب الروسيه دوما اعطى
موافقته الاوليه على تشريع سيسمح لوزاره
الدفاع بتوقيع عقود مع مجرمين مشتبه بهم
او مدانين للقتال في اوكرانيا وهنا سيحصل
المقاتلون المتطوعون على جميع المزايا
والضمانات التي تحصل عليها القوات
النظاميه بما في ذلك تقديم الدعم لهم
ولعائلاتهم اذا اصيبوا او قتلوا هذه
الخطوه جاءت بعد مساء طويله الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين حاول من خلالها اخضاع كل
القوات المواليه لروسيا في اوكرانيا وذلك
بمساعده وزاره الدفاع وكذلك لاخضاع مجموعه
فاغنر وفق تقرير صادر عن
رئيس الروسي ومن خلال هذه الخطوه يسعى
لاخداع فاجنر لسلطه وزاره الدفاع دعما
لمبادره يشويجو التي رفض مؤسس
فاجنراع لها حيث يواصل هو الاخر اتهامه
لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه بعرقله امداد قواته
بالسلاح في ميدان المعركه وايضا بالتخلي
عن اراضي في منطقه الحدوديه مع اوكرانيا
الخلاف اذا بات واضحا في العلم بين بوتين
وطباخه في الفتره الاخيره حيث اعتبر مؤسس
فاجنر طلب وزاره الدفاع الروسيه من
المتطوعين بتوقيع عقود بانه عار
عندما شاركنا لاول مره في هذه الحرب لم
يقل احد اننا سنكون مضطرين لتوقيع صفقات
مع وزاره الدفاع الروسيه لا احد من مقاتل
فاجنر مستعد للسير في طريق العار هذا مره
اخرى لهذا السبب لا احد منهم سيوقع العقود
حرب التصريحات المضاده زيدت بعد ان قالت
وزاره الدفاعيه الروسيه انها وقعت عقدا مع
مجموعه القوات الخاصه الشيشانيه المعروفه
باسم كتيبه احمد وذلك بعد يوم من رفض
بريجو جين توقيعه على عقد ممثل
يعتبر مجموعته مفتاح القوه وهي التي حققت
اكبر الانتصارات في الميدان فهو يواصل
تعهده بعدم العمل تحت قياده شويغو مشيرا
ايضا الى رغبه الجيش في ابعاد مجموعته عن
ساحه المعركه في اوكرانيا ومع عوده
الخلافات بين الجيش وجماعه فاجنر للواجهه
من جديد تتزايد المخاوف والتساؤلات حول
الاستراتيجيه التي يمكن ان يلجا اليها
بوتين لتدارك الموقف واحتواء الوضع الذي
يمكن ان يخرج عن السيطره
[موسيقى]
حول حرب تصريحات المضاده بين زعيم فيرنا
وجنرال شويغو ورفضي عناصر توقيعه تعاقدات
مع الجيش القتال في اوكرانيا وسماح
البرلمان الروسي المجرمين للقتال في
اوكرانيا الى جانب الجيش ينضم الا مدينه
اين تكمن الدوافع الحقيقيه وراء اللجوء
الجيش الروسي او وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
لتجنيد مدانين ومجرمين في صفوفها في هذا
التوقيت هل الامر مرتبط بشكل او باخر
بالخلافات العميقه مع
فيما يتعلق يعني في هذا الخلاف الذي نشهده
ويتداول منذ فتره هناك تدخيل طبعا اعلاني
لما يحدث وذلك لتوظيفه يعني سياسيا من
خلال يعني المنظومه الغربيه ومن خلال كييف
لكن في حقيقه الحال يعني هناك يعني بعض
المناورات هناك بعض الامتيازات يعني
الماديه والتي لا يريد ان يخسرها من خلال
هذه العمليه وكان يعني المساله تبدو انها
سحب البساط من تحته هذه المساله لا تروق
له فلذلك يعني نراه الاعلام من خلال
التصريحات يعني الناريه وهذه الهجومات لكن
يعني التصميم ايضا لاعلامي يدخل في مساحه
يعني ان لا يوجد تقريبا يعني قوه للجيش
الروسي والكل الاعتماد على قوات
وغيرها لا اعتقد ذلك يعني الساحه اليوم
الساحه العسكريه على عده جبهات وكانت فقط
مناطقة يعني منطقه في هذه
يعني بمشهد اخر نرى الدخول الف
علي تدمير المعدات يعني الامريكيه
والفرنسيه
والالمانيه وهذا كله يعني بعد بدء
اوكرانيا بعمليه الهجوم المضاد والذي يعني
انعته في الهجوم الانتحار يعني مقاطعه لكن
اذا كانت الخلافات بين فاغنر والدفاع
الروسيه ترى فيها تطهير الاعلاميه لماذا
استعانت اداره الدفاع الاوكرانيه الدفاع
الروسيه بالمجرمين والمدانين في صوفيا
يعني هذه
يعني في فبراير من العام الماضي ايضا يعني
عندما اطلق جيليسكي جميع المساجين يعني كل
السجون وسلحهم بدون تدريب لم احد يتكلم عن
هذه القضيه بما يتعلق يعني في روسيا هذه
فرصه يعني لتكثير عن الجنوب وهي كانت يعني
معتاده وامورست يعني حتى في الحرب
العالميه الثانيه وهي يعني الحفاظ على
القطاعات القويه يعني العسكريه وايضا يعني
اعطاء الفرصه لهؤلاء المحكومين يعني
للدفاع عن عن وطنهم فلذلك يعني ايضا ارى
انه لكن هل يمكن التعويل عليهم في هذه
المعارك هل يملكون عقيده قتاليه مثل الجيش
الروسي ومثل القوات الاوكرانيه في النهايه
هم يواجهون جيشا نظاميا هو الجيش
الاوكراني بالتاكيد
يعني
من هؤلاء هو سيذهب يعني فورا الى الجبهه
هناك حتى يعني للمتطوعين هناك اليات
للتدريبيه لا تقل عن ثلاثه اشهر للتدريب
العسكري ولن يزج بهم يعني في المواقع
الاماميه هذا يعني سيعتبر
العسكريه لكن يعني الجيوش كما كما تعرف
سيدي الكريم يعني هناك فئات هناك فرق
مسانده امدادات فلذلك لا يمكن القول بانهم
سيكونون يعني وقودا على الجبهات التي
نراها مستعره اليوم
طيب شكرا لك الدكتور عمار قناه
منبول
علوم السياسيه تحياتي
مشاهدينا ننتقل الى اصابه وهذا المؤتمر
الصحفي المتحدث الرسمي باسم وزاره
الخارجيه الروسيه ماريا زخرفه
كما قال الرئيس الفرنسي مانويل ماكرون
بانهم قاموا بامداد الاسلحه والذخيره
والعربات المدرعه وكذلك قاموا بدعم زياده
الدعم اللوجستي
ربما انهم لا يعلمون ماذا يفعلون وما الذي
يقومون به او هذه كذبه حقيقيه من قبلهم
يقومون باظهارها للعالم بالطبع الولايات
المتحده ايضا تقوم بصب الوقود على النار
وفي نفس اليوم في اتاني عشر مليون يورو
قال وزير الخارجيه انطونيو
مصممه على مواصله تقديم اقصى دعم
لاوكرانيا حتى
تنجح في ساحه هذه المعركه
ولكن الان
لديهم ربما هدف اخر وكما قاموا بالنطق به
بانهم هدفهم ربما هناك هو قتل عدد اكبر من
الروس ولكنهم لا يقومون باجراء احصاءات
حول ذلك لان هؤلاء الناس يعتبرون بالنسبه
لهم كماده
للاستهلاك فقط او وقودا لحربهم
مساعدات جديده
وبالنسبه له من اجل ان تبدا المفاوضات
فان الحل الوحيد لذلك هو قتل اكثر عدد
اكبر من الروس
مفاجي هذا الاسلوب وهذا التعامل لم يسبق
له ان
تضم كان في اي وقت من قبل
المخرجون السياسيون الذين يجلسون في البيت
الابيض هم الذين من يحركون كل هذا هذه
المسرحيه
وادائها
فانا كل الامكانيات والفرص للقيام باجراء
المفاوضات النظام كياب هو من قام بتقويضها
ومنعها فهي
فهذا النظام هو من قد منع نفسه من الوصول
الى تسويه او الى حل لهذا الوضع
الحادي عشر من يونيو رئيس مكتب اوكرانيا
بانه في البدايه لا توجد
ايه مخاطر بالنسبه
لاوروبا او لاوكرانيا
وان المفاوضات هذه ستكون بلا معنى وخطيره
بالنسبه لاوكرانيا واوروبا
ربما اذا كان هذا المنطق الذي
يتحدثون به
يرجون خذوا مستوره فان هناك مجرى واضح
وصريح ومعترف به عبر التاريخ
في الحادي عشر من يونيو في يوم القديسيين
في كييفا
السلطات
اخذت بشريكس لافا بشكل غير رسمي من
المؤمنين
معكم في متابعه لهذا المؤتمر الصحفي
للمتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه
ماريا زخرفه
[موسيقى]
مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعض الفاصل
في شمال دارفور عشرات القتلى في اشتباكات
عنيفه بمخيبه النازحين وتحذيرات امميه
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد عبرت الحكومه
السودانيه عن رفضها رئاسه كينا للجنه
للجنه ايجاد المعنيه بحل الازمه في
السودان والتي تمخضت عن قيمه جيبوتي
الاخيره وقال مصدر الحكومي سوداني ان
كينيا الدعم السريع وتقدم المسانده لهم
بحسب تعبيره واصبح الطرفا غير محايد في
الازمه واضاف ان الحكومه السودانيه ستبلغ
بل ستبلغ مجموعه ايجاد برفضها
[موسيقى]
دان سفير الاتحاد الاوروبي في السودان
ايرلنديال غرب امس وصف حدث القتل بالوحشيه
والمروع وقال التحالف السوداني الذي كان
يراسه الوالي خميس عبد الله ابو بكر ان
ميليشيا دعمت بقتل الوالي في مدينه
الجنينه واستنكرت السلوك الذي وصفته بانه
يتنافى مع المواثيق الدوليه في التعامل مع
الاسرع
مقتل والي غربي دارفور في الجنينه وطرف
الصراع في السودان يتهمان بعضهما
الجيش السوداني اكد ان قوات الدعم السريع
هي من اعتقلت واغتالت خميس عبد الله ابكر
في عمليه وحشيه ندين حادثه الاغتيال ولا
علاقه لولي غرب دارفور بمجريات الصراع
الحاليه بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع اما
مستشار قوات الدعم السريع عمران عبد الله
حسن فحمل الجيش مسؤوليه مقتل ابكر وقال ان
السودان يعيش في حاله حرب ولا مكان امن في
دارفور عناصر متفلته تقف خلف مقتل والي
غرب دارفور من جهتها حركه العدل والمساواه
السودانيه اتهمت ميليشيات مسلحه بالوقوف
وراء الاغتيال
اما التحالف السوداني فدعا المجتمع الدولي
للتحقيق في مقتل والي غرب دارفور وشدد على
انه يحتفظ بحق الرد
ابكر كان قد ناشر وقف اطلاق النار في
الجنينه وكشف تحت صوت الرصاص ان القتال
الدائر دمر المدينه باكملها اليوم احنا
عندنا اعداد كبيره جدا من الجرحى
مراكزه هي كلها تم تدميره تماما اليوم
جنينه
كلها بتتدمرت مدير الاعلان في حكومه اقليم
دارفور موسى داوود سلط الضوء على الوضع
الانساني الصعب في الجنينه واشار بدوره
الى ان عدد القتلى خلال المواجهات بلغ
اكثر من الف شخص
انتقلت الازمه السودانيه اذا انشهرت اليوم
بعمليه اعتقال وغتيان راح ضحيتها ولغرب
دار الفرس عبد الله بكر وذلك الاتهامات
بين الجيش وقوه الدعم السريع بشان من نفذ
عمليه الاغتيال نتابع
[موسيقى]
من القاهره مشاهدينا معنا المحلل السياسي
السوداني عمار عوض اهلا بك سيد عمار بدايه
ما الذي يعنيه مقتل والي غرب دارفور في
هذه المرحله من الازمه في السودان ومن
الذي يتحمل مسؤوليه مقتله
مقتل
الشهيد والي غربي دارفور صديقنا واخانا
الاكبر كبرة خميس ابو بكر الجنرال خميس
ابو بكر هو يدخل هذه المنطقه في اتون حرب
اهليه
وهذه هي مقدماتها كانت هنالك لاكثر من 23
يوم التي مضت كانت مدينه الجنينه
ان تحت وطاهه الفروقات
وانعدام الاتصالات وتدمير المستشفيات
وغيره الان عندما تقول قوات التحالف
السودانيه انها تحتفظ بحق الرد ذلك علينا
ان نتوقع ان في الايام القادمه
تحدث اشياء ليست كريمه في حق السودانيين
او في حق الحرب الان لكل فعل رد فعل
الغضب الذي يعتمر في قلوب الناس من شعب
المساليد نتيجه
للهجمات الممنهجه التي تتم عليهم والتي
طرت الرئيس بعثه اليونيتامس للحديث مباشره
على ان ما يحدث في الجنينه يرقى لي جرائم
حربي وجرائم ضد الانسانيه ولاول مره الامم
المتحده تلقي باتهام مبطن لقوات الدعم
السريع عندما غالت ان المسؤوليه تقع على
قوات الدعم السريع في مدينه الجنينه
كل ذلك لا ينذر بخير باي حال من الاحوال
واننا ستكون هذه نقطه مفصليه في طريق
الصراع في دارفور وفي طريق الصراع هل ترجح
فرضيه وقوف الدعم السريع وراى مقتلي هذا
الالوان السيد الوالي ام ان هناك طرف اخرى
وما شاركت في هذه العمليه الان هناك بعض
التحليلات التي تشير الى ربما هناك تورط
في اطراف دوليه ترى في مصلحته ترى مصلحته
في استمرار هذا النزاع والتوتر في السودان
بغض النظر اصلا هذه الحرب اذا اتينا لك
الايادي الاجنبيه او الدوليه علينا ان
نعود الى اللحظه التي اقر فيها المجتمع
الدولي خروج قوات يونمت التي رفضناها نحن
كمراقبين وكاعلام وكسودانيين وغير ولكن
كان القرار هو ان تخرج قوات بعثه الامم
المتحده يونايت والتي تم الاستعاظ عنها
بقوات حمايه المدنيين في دارفور وهذه
القوات انت تعلم وانا اعلم لم تقدم اي شيء
طوال هذه الفتره التي دخلت فيها كانت
المجازر مستمره وغيره
الطواطؤ الدولي ليس
ليس جديد على على السودانيين اكثر من 30
يوما كانت تقيم فيها جنينه ودارفور ولكن
كان ليس هنالك احد يتحدث نحن نعلم
الصراعات الاقليميه فرنسا اجانس روسيا من
الولايات المتحده غينيس روسيا غير من
الايادي الاجنبيه التي تستغل
اللي موجوده في السودان لكن المسؤوليه
مسؤوليه الدعم السريع
الدعم السريع هو المسؤول لان الذين يظهرون
في مقاطع الفيديو والذين تم تحديدهم
بالاسماء لحظه اعتقال هذا الوالي الذي قتل
غدرا هؤلاء ينتمون لقوات الدعم السريع
لديهم رتب عسكريه معروفه بل المحزم ان
احدهم هو جار السيد الوالي في الذي قتل هم
جيران ومع ذلك بغض النظر على انهم هل تم
اختطافه بعد اعتقاله من قوات الدعم السريع
هل اتت شياطين من الانس والجن وقتلوه لكن
المسؤوليه تبقى امام الشخص الذي يظهر في
الفيديو وهو يقود الوالي الى داخل المعتقل
وهذه اخر صوره للوالي علي ان يتحمل
المسؤوليه ليس هنالك شخص اخر ولكن طبعا
هذه القضايا تقرر فيها الجنائيه وتغير
تغرر فيها التحقيقات الجنائيه نحن في
الاعلام نحكم الظواهر بالشواهد وليس لدينا
ادله
على ذلك لكن ما يجب ان يقوله الانسان في
هذه الفرصه على اصدقائنا في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه الذين يعملون على وقف اطلاق
النار مضاعفه جهودهم وليس ترك السودان
والاستمرار في تعليق هذه المحادثات او
الذهاب بقضيه السودان الى مجاهل افريقيا
وذلك الثوره جميع طفره تساؤلات حول
استثماريه هذه المفاوضات في فقه المقبله
من الجيش قوات الدعم
القاهره السياسيه السوداني عمار وتحياتي
يصوت البرلمان الاوروبي اليوم مشاهدينا
الخميس على مشروع قرار يدين استماره
المعارك في السودان وخرق طرفي الصراع
الاتفاقات وقف النار وكان الاتحاد
الاوروبي هدد بفرض عقوبات على طرفين نزاع
في السودان انتهاك القانون الانساني
الدولي وعرقله عمل الفرق الامميه في ايصال
مساعده الانسانيه اضافه الى اجبار اكثر من
مليون شخص على النزوح وفق تقارير امميه
بعد تطورات الاخيره في دارفور اعلان
المفوض السامي الامم المتحده لشؤون
اللاجئين عن مقتل اكثر من 100 شخص في
اشتباكات عنيفه
ظهر لمخيمات النازحين وحولها في ولايه
الشمال دارفور السودانيه وحضر جراندي
مشاهدينا عبر حسابه على تويتر من وجود
تقارير مروعه عنف جنسي اتجاه النساء
والفتيات مؤكدا ان الوضع في ولايه شمال
دارفور سيتفاقم ما لم تتفق اطراف النزاع
على انهاء القتال الذي يدمر السودان
ارقام النصادم ايضا كشف عنها المفوض
السامي الامم المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين تظهر
ارتفاعا غير مسبوق في عدد النازحين في
العالم
عفوا
يتجاوز قصرا حاجز المئه مليون نشاهد
التفاصيل المشاهدين
هروب متتاليه وازمات انسانيه متشابهه تجعل
عمليه النزوح ضروره وليست خيارا بالنسبه
لكثيرين لينزح قصرا الى المناطق الاكثر
امانا نحو 110 ملايين شخص حول العالم
مستوى قياسي يمثل اكبر قفزه سنويه على
الاطلاق كشفت عنها مفوضيه شؤون اللاجئين
فهذه هي المره الاولى التي تتجاوز فيها
اعداد النازحين قصرا حاجزا المئه مليون
ربما تتذكر قبل عامين فقط او ربما في
العام الماضي عندما اعلنا لاول مره اننا
قد تجاوزنا 100 مليون نازح حسن تمت اضافه
عشره بالمئه اكثر بالفعل الى هذا الرقم
انه ادانه الى حد بعيد لحاله عالمنا
مفوضيه اللاجئين كشفت في تقرير لها ان عدد
النازحين زاد بنحو 19 مليون منذ 2019
ويرجع الامر بصوره اساسيه الى صراع مستمر
في السودان واوكرانيا فكل شخص من بين كل
اربعه وسبعين فردا حول العالم هو حاليا من
النازحين
تعددت اسباب ظاهره النزوح القسري والماساه
واحده فالبعض يهرب من الحروب العدائيه
احيانا ومن الظروف المناخيه احيانا اخرى
لدينا 110 ملايين شخص فرو بسبب الصراع
والاضطهاد والتمييز والعنف وغالبا ما
يختلطون بدوافع اخرى لاسيما تاثير تغير
المناخ المستوى العالمي لنزوح القصر كان
مستقرا على مدار العقدين اللذين سبق
الصراع السوري فقد بلغ عدد النازحين بحسب
تقرير النزوح القسري عند 40 مليون لاجئ
داخليا الا ان المستوى يشهد ارتفاعا سنويا
منذ ذلك الحين لتبقى النزاعات الدوليه هي
المحرك الاساسي لهذه القضايا الانسانيه
[موسيقى]
قال وزير الخارجي العماني بدر البوسعيدي
ان ايران والولايات المتحده تقتربان من
وضع اللمسات النهائيه على اتفاق بشان
اطلاق سراح امريكيين في طهران مشيرا الى
ان المساله تنحصر في امور فنيه فقط واوضح
الوزير ان ايران لديها شروط اولها الافراج
عن اصول ايرانيه بمليارات الدولارات مجمده
في بنوك كوريه جنوبيه بسبب عقوبات امريكيه
وزير الخارجيه العماني عبر عن تفاؤله حول
الاتفاق النووي الايراني الذي ابرم في عام
2015 قائلا ان هناك اجواء ايجابيه فيما
يخص الملف النووي وان بلاده تعتقد ان
القياده الايرانيه جاده بشان التوصل الى
اتفاق
مشاهدينا ينضم الينا من لندن الباحث في
الشان الايراني وجدان عبد الرحمن اهلا بك
سيد وجدان معنا في هذه الساعه الاخباريه
حتى وقت قريب كنا نتحدث عن فشل مفاوضات
فيينا وصعوبه التواصل لاتفاق امريكي
ايراني في مثل هذه الظروف تصريحات وزير
خارجيه العمانيه الان هل تعني ان هناك
انفراجه ربما حدثت بين البلدين في هذه
التفاهمات
تحياتي لك يا استاذ احمد ولا متابعي قناه
العربيه الكرام لا اعتقد انه موضوع
الاتفاقيه 2015 يتم الحديث عنها وانما
هنالك الحديث عن اتفاقيه مواقفه ما بين
الجانبين الايراني والامريكي واعتقد
المرشد الايراني رسم نوح هذه الاتفاقيه
حيث اعلن بانه يجب ان لا يتم
المساس بالبنيه التحتيه للمنشات النوويه
الايرانيه بمعنى ان تبقى اجهزه الطرد
المركزي والتقسيب اليورانيوم عاليه
التقسيم
لاثبات الستين في الميه وايضا الكميه
الموجوده لذلك اعتقد انه هذه الاتفاقيه
ستكون اتفاقيه مؤقته فقط ما بين ايران
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه تختص فقط حول
ان ايران تقوم بتجميد عمل
التقسيم بنسب عاليه لا يتجاوز النسبه 60
في المئه مقابل الافراج عن السجناء
الامريكي وايضا في المقابل تحصل ايران على
اموالها في العراق وكوريا الجنوبيه واعلان
ايران بان الحصول على مبلغ من اموالها ما
يقارب ثلاثه مليار دولار من العراق اعتقد
انه بالفعل هذه الخطه تم العمل عليها
والتوافق عليها بغيت الافراج عن السجناء
الامريكيين لكن في نهايه المطاف اعتقد انه
رغم انه تفضل طيب انا اعتذر منك على
المقاطعه دعم الوقت سيد وجدان كنت معنا من
لندن ارباحيت في الشارع الايراني عبد
الرحمن شكرا جزيلا لك
مشاهدينا اتفاق امني تاريخي قد يكون سلاحا
امريكيا جديدا لتطويق الصين اذا حصلت
الولايات المتحده على حق استخدام قواعده
ومنشاه عسكريه رئيسيه في ابواغينيا
الجديده دون عوائق الاتفاق مشاهدينا الذي
كان سريا قبل ان يعرض على برلمان بابواي
الجديده اخيرا سيسمح للولايات المتحده
بنشر قوات وسفن في المطارات الرئيسيه
بالاضافه الى مواقع مثل قاعده لومبورم
البحريه في جزيره مانوس وميناء بحري في
العاصمه بورت موريسبي كما ينص على منح
واشنطن حق الدخول بلا عراقي الى مواقع من
اجل تخزين مسبق لمعدات وامدادات واعتاد
فضلا عن منحها حق استخدام حصري لبعض
القطاعات في القواعد التي يمكن ان تشهد
انشطه بناء وبذلك تكون بابوجيني الجديده
الغنيه بالموارد الطبيعيه والقريبه من طرق
شحن الرئيسيه لاعبا اساسيا في المواجهه
الدبلوماسيه بين واشنطن وبكين
ومن التوتر في المحيط الهادئ الى اختبار
النوايا بين واشنطن وبكين حيث اكد مسؤول
امريكي في مكافحه المخدرات انه واشنطن
ستسعى لتعزيز التعاون مع الصين لوقف دخول
ماده الفينتانيل المخدره الى الولايات
المتحده قبيل زياره لوزير الخارجي
وتعتبر هذه الماده من اخطر المواد المخدره
التي تنتشر في الولايات المتحده
بعيدا عن السياسه واشنطن تختبر نوايا بكين
اداره الرئيس جو بايدن اعلنتها صراحه
وقررت تعزيز التعاون مع الصين لوقف دخول
ماده الفانتان الى المخدرة الى الولايات
المتحده بوند قد يكون اساسيا على جدول
اعمال زياره وزير الخارجيه انطوني بلينكن
الى بكين الفانتان المخدر صناعي اقوى من
الهيروين بما يصل الى 50 مره يتم خلطه مع
مخدرات غير قانونيه اخرى معدل الوفيات
الناجمه عن تعاطي جرعات زائده من
الفانتانيل ارتفع لاكثر من ثلاثه امثاله
بين عامي 2016
حسب المراكز الامريكيه لمكافحه الامراض
والوقايه منها واشنطن تضع منع دخول المواد
المستخدمه في صنع الفانتان الى القادمه من
الصين ضمن اولوياتها غير ان المسؤولين
الامريكيين يرون ان نظرائهم الصينيين لا
يب دون حماسا كبيرا للتعاون
بلاينكن سيكون اكبر مسؤول بالحكومه
الامريكيه يزور الصين منذ تولي الرئيس
بايدن السلطه
بلال البستاني العربيه
في الحلف بشان مستقبله بعد ان اتحد في
الفتره الماضيه بخصوص الحرب الدائره على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه
نلتقي هنا بينما تشن اوكرانيا هجوما مضادا
كبيرا لا يزال في الايام الاولى ولا نعرف
ان كان سيمثلون نقطه تحول في الحرب لكننا
نرى ان الاوكرانيين يحرزون تقدما ويحررون
المزيد من الاراضي نعلم ان المزيد من
المكاسب تزيد قوه اوكرانيا على طاوله
المفاوضات
اشارت الى ان معارضه بولندا لاختيار امين
عام جديد للحلف من دول من دول من دول
الشمال التي تضم السويد الدنماركا النرويج
تكمن في رغبتها في اختيار شخص من دول
الجناح الشرقي للمنصب الاعلى بالحلف واضاف
المسؤولون الغربيون ان المقاومه التي
تبديها وارسو قد تحرم رئيسه وزراء
الدنمارك من المنصب اذ يجب اختيار الامين
العام لحلف الناتو باجماع الدول الاعضاء
التي يبلغ عددها احدى وثلاثين دوله واشارت
جورنال نقلا عن مسؤولين اوروبيين ان بعضا
من دول الجناح الشرقي للناتو تتخوف من ان
يقوض الترشح المحتمل لرئيسه وزراء
الدنمارك احتجاجات الحلف من في مواجهه
روسيا وتعتقد بولندا ان الحلف يجب ان يبعث
برساله قويه الى موسكو بتعيين امين عام
لحلف الناتو ينحدر من احدى الدول التي
كانت ذات يوم جزءا من الاتحاد السوفيتي
على الجانب الاخر تتخوف العديد من الدول
الغربيه من ان تنظر موسكو الى ترشيح امين
عام من الجناح الشرقي باعتباره عملا
استفزازيا لانه يضع قياده الحلف على اعتاب
روسيا
[موسيقى]
تبدا اليوم يا ست المحاكمه الاولى لرئيس
بلديه اسطنبول الكبرى اكرم امام اوغلو على
خلفيه اتهامه بالفساد بموجب تقارير تقارير
صادره عن وزاره الداخليه وشدد محامي عمده
اسطنبول سيرجيان
هذه الدعوه دعوه امام اوغلو الدعوه بحقه
رفعت دون اي سند قانوني واضاف سيرجان
بولات ان المسار الزمني لهذه المحاكمه
سيكون طويلا وقد تستمر على اقل تقدير لما
يتراوح بين عام ونصف الى عامين مؤكدا ان
الدعوه كانت معلقه واغلقت تحقيق بشانها في
السابق وان ابلو لم يكن بل ان اكرم امام
اوغلو لم يكن مسؤولا اي مناقصات التي لا
تحمل توقيعه على الاطلاق والى جانب امام
اول يمثل ايضا سته متهمين اخرين في القضيه
نفسها حيال مزاعم فساد تتعلق بمناقصات
يتهم عمله اسطنبول على اثرها بهدر المال
العام قبل سنوات
في متابعاتي محاكمه ترامب التاريخيه جاء
تصريح جديد للرئيس الامريكي السابق قد يعد
بمثابه اعتراف بعمق مشكلاته القانونيه حيث
قال عبر منصه
يقولون ان سرقه الاسرار النوويه والعسكريه
جريمه خطيره للغايه مؤكده انه بصفته
الرئيس المفضل لامريكا قام بفرض قوانين
الوثائق السريه لولايات المتحده بقوه
شديده على حد وصفه كما اعتبر انه عندما
طلب لمساعده
الشخصيه قبل مغادرته البيت الابيض كان
واثقا من انه لن يضع اي اسرار نوويه في
الصناديق اشار ايضا الى ان مساعده كرجل من
البحريه يعرف ان هذا سيكون غير قانوني
ويمكن حتى ان يوقعه في مشكله مؤكده في
الوقت ذاته انه لا يصدق مزاعم وزاره العدل
حول ان مساعده فعل هذا التصرف وانه سينتظر
ما يقوله القاضي
في خطوه متوقعه على نطاق واسع قرر
الاحتياطي الفيدرالي الامريكي تثبيت
معدلات الفائده الرئيسيه للمره الاولى منذ
يناير 2022
وبعدما رفع المركز الامريكي معدلات
الفائده 10 مرات متتاليه اعتبار من مارس
2022 صوتت لجنه لجنه تحديد معدلات الفائده
في الاحتياطيه الفيدرالي لصالح الابقاء
على معدلات الفائده الحاليه مشاهدينا دواء
لانقاص الوزن منذ اشهر والدواء يتصدر
محركات البحث والترند على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي فقد اثنى المشاهير على مفعوله
السحري وشارك ايضا مؤثر تيك توك تجاربهم
المذهله مع ما ادى الى اقبالنا شديد على
المنتج وفقدانه من الاسواق نتابع
من يفكر بانقاص وزنه فبالتاكيد صادفه
الحديث عن هذا الدواء اوزنبك منتج طبي
مخصص لمرضى السكري شهد اقبالا جنونيا بحثا
عن التنحيف ما ادى الى فقدانه من الاسواق
واثاره قلق الاطباء
للدواء السحري بدائل كدواء مونجارو مثلا
لكن البديل الذي يثير اكبر ضجه الان هو
البديل الطبيعي الارخص والمتاح بسهوله في
الصيدليات وهو البربرين او المعروف بنيتشر
اوزمبك هكذا يقول الاطباء
البربرين يعتبره الباحثون مساعدا مكملا
لعلاج حالات مثل تعديل ضغط الدم ومقاومه
الانسولين وتنظيم الكوليسترول فهو مركب
كيميائي مستخرج من نباتات مثل خاتم الذهب
والبربريس عاده يباعك مكمل غذائي في
كبسولات مليئه بمسحوق اصفر اللون
تم استخدام المركب في اسيا منذ اكثر من
2000 سنه وصار علاجا للشكاوى المعديه
والمعويه وبحسب تاكيدات الخبراء فانه قادر
بالفعل على انقاص الوزن لا بل انه يحقق
نتائج اكثر ضمانا من اوزمبك الذي لا تزال
فعاليته مسار جدل وكونه منتجا فعالا بحسب
الاطباء فهذا لا يغني عن بعض الاثار
الجانبيه الموثقه كالغثيان وارتفاع ضغط
الدم وارتعاش اليدين والقدمين بالاضافه
لتقلصات في الرحم لدى الحوامل
بشكل عام مركب امن هكذا تشير الدراسات لكن
الخوف هو من تسويقه دون ضوابط
ان نذكر بابرز العناوين
روسيا تقول انها تفشل بل انها تفشل هجوم
اوكرانيا بالمسيرات على جزيره القرم وكيف
تسقط 20 مسيره روسيه
الحكومه السودانيه تتهمكيه بايواء الدعم
السريع والاتحاد الاوروبي يصفوختي الا غرب
دارفور بالمروع
سلطنه عمان تعلن عن اتفاق وشيك الاطلاق
سراح امريكيين محتجزين في طهران
ناهيتو هذه الساعه الاخباريه مشاهدينا
شكرا حسن المتابعه وكونوا بعافيه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات